GOOD AFTERNOON -- AND WE ARE NOW
GOING TO CALL TO ORDER THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES SUB.
ONE I'D LIKE TO REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT WE ARE ASKING THAT TO THE
PANELISTS -- BASIS THINK TEN
YOUR PRESENTATION AND LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC THAT IS GOING
TO GIVE COMMENT AT THE END WE
ASK THAT YOU LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND I'D LET'S BEGIN WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE OVERVIEW OF
DEPARTMENT BUDGET FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
TESTIMONY BE IN THE ORDER NOTED.
IN THE AGENDA [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BUT DOCTOR SMITH YEAH LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH YOU YOU ARE THE
DIRECTOR THANK YOU YES I'M
DOCTOR KAREN SMITH I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
WE'RE HERE TO GIVE YOU A VERY
SUCCINCT OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET
AND TO DO THAT I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO MR NEWNESS OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY THANK YOU SO.
MY NAME IS BRANDON AND SOME THE
CHIEF DEPUTY FOR OPERATIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT.
OF COURSE THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
TO OPTIMIZE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
CITY PAGES FUNDAMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
COMPREHENSIVE IN SCOPE AND WE
MAINTAIN CLOSE COORDINATION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO FULFILL
THIS MISSION -- KEY ACTIVITIES
OF OUR DEPARTMENT AND SERVICES --
THAT HELP US ACHIEVE OUR MISSION
INCLUDE PROTECTING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THE THREAT OF
PREVENTABLE INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
AND PROVIDING RELIABLE AND
ACCURATE PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY SERVICES AND
INFORMATION ABOUT HEALTH THREATS.
IT ALSO INCLUDES PROVIDING
NUTRITIONAL SUPPORT TO LOW
INCOME WOMEN INFANTS AND
CHILDREN.
AND SCREENING NEWBORNS AND
PREGNANT WOMEN FOR GENETIC
DISEASES.
PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO WORKS TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF FOOD AND
BOTTLED WATER HELPS REDUCE
SMOKING AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
PUBLIC.
AND WORKS TO PREVENT CHRONIC
DISEASE AND CONDITIONS SUCH AS
DIABETES CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
CANCER ASTHMA AND OTHERS -- AS
WAS REQUESTED IN THE AGENDA OF
PROVIDE YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR -- SO TO
SUPPORT THE FUNCTIONS THAT I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY -- OUR
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS A BUDGET
OF APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S FOR BOTH
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND WE MANAGE A TEAM OF
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED STAFF.
MUCH OF OUR FUNDING SOURCES COME
FROM APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
DIFFERENT SPECIAL FUNDING
SOURCES ANOTHER PROXIMALLY HALF
OF OUR BUDGET IS PROVIDED
THROUGH FEDERAL GRANTS.
IN ABOUT 6% OF OUR BUDGET COMES
TO THE STATE GENERAL FUND AND
THEN ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THAT
TOTAL FUNDING IS ACTUALLY USED
TO PROVIDE.
ASSISTANCE FOR LOW -- FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS -- THIS YEAR
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AS WAS
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA WE HAVE
AN APPROXIMATELY FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE OVER A
YEAR OVER YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND NINETEEN TWENTY THE PROPOSAL
WILL COME TO YOU IN THE FORM OF
SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT BCP'S THAT
WE HAVE AND THEN WE HAVE UPDATES.
TO OUR FOUR DIFFERENT ESTIMATES.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT -- SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THAT A HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU AND
THEN ALL OF THOSE WILL BE
TOUCHED ON TODAY WITH OUR FOLKS --
FROM OUR CENTERS WHO WILL
DISCUSS THESE DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS WITH YOU BUT THE
HIGHLIGHT WE DO HAVE A PROPOSAL
FOR SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR A NEW EXPAND A CONTRACT WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE HELPLESS REFORM LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION ACTIVITIES --
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE HAVE A TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND ASK TO
EXPAND OUR CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAM.
I'M AND WE'LL DO THAT IN
COORDINATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
AT THE PROGRAM EXPANSION WILL
FOCUS ON YOUNG LOW INCOME
MOTHERS AND PROVIDE A WIDER
RANGE OF HOME VISITING MODELS
BASED ON VARYING FAMILY NEEDS.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ASK OF SEVEN AND
A HALF MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE EXPANSION OF OUR BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM.
WE HAVE A TWO MILLION DOLLAR --
CONTINUATION OF FUNDING FOR OUR
TO PREVENT SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASES AND THEN FINALLY THE
OTHER PROPOSAL THAT ALL
HIGHLIGHT IS THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
PROGRAM THAT KIND OF SPANS TWO
DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS ONE IS TO
CONTINUE THE GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE.
AND THEN THEY'RE ALSO RESOURCES
IN THEIR TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON
ALZHEIMER'S PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS.
SUCH A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
OUR PROPOSALS I MENTION YOU'LL
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THOSE IN MUCH
MORE DETAIL FROM THE REST OF THE
PALACE BUT ALL IN THE MY
COMMENTS THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK.
I HAVE SUSAN FINELLI NO SEE I AM
HERE IN SUSAN'S PLACE SHE'S IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TODAY.
AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE
[inaudible]
NOBODY COMES.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE HELLO YEAH THAT'S ME WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR KIND
ABOUT THE OVERVIEW.
THINK VERY GOOD.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELL VERY GOOD THAT WAS A VERY
SUCCINCT.
OVERVIEW THE BUDGET I THINK
EVERYBODY'S INTERESTED IN THE
DETAILS NOW.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEN LET'S GO TO ISSUE.
TO S. T. D. FUNDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF DR
GIL CHAVEZ TIME DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR INFECTIONS THE SUCCESS THAT
CV PH.
AS YOU.
PROBABLY HAVE HEARD IN THE NEWS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN EXPERIENCING
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
TEST FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
IT IS.
NOW THE CASE THAT WE DID RECEIVE
REPORTS FROM MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS TO THE CASES
IN THE STATE EVERY YEAR.
AND THAT'S ABOUT A 45% INCREASE
FOR JUST THE LAST. FOUR YEARS.
OUR PROVISIONAL DATA FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN I SHOWS
THAT UNFORTUNATELY ON THE RATE
OF INCREASE CONTINUES ON A AND
WE ARE GOING TO SEE MORE CASES
WHEN THE DATA FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARE FINALIZING WE SAW.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I WITHIN
THESE INCREASES SO WE KNOW THAT
THE RATES OF EVERY SINGLE STV
ARE INCREASING.
BUT VERY CONCERNING OUR THE
INCREASES IN THE RATES OF
SYPHILIS.
I AM PARTICULARLY WITHIN CITY
POLICE THEIR CASES OF CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS.
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS USED TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WE NEVER SELL IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOW WE SEE A CASES REGULARLY.
HI JOE STING TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ALONE WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE CASES OF
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS.
HI THIS CASES ARE VERY TRAGIC
AND THEY ARE ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE.
A AND THERE REALLY SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING.
IN ADDITION IN THIS THE THE
RATES WE SEE SOME SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES.
WE SEE THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
PARTICULARLY COVERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RATES.
HOT SO STV INCREASES ARE ALSO ON
THE ISSUE OF HEALTH EQUITY.
AND AN ISSUE OF SOCIAL JUSTICE.
SO THE DEPARTMENT HAS A PROPOSAL
FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO LOCAL
ISSUES THINS.
OUT SO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN INVESTMENTS THAT YOU
ALL MADE -- LAST YEAR WHERE WE
WERE YOU FUNDED A STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL FOR THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
HI THAT STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL WAS
FOUNDED ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
ALSO WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GOOD WORK THAT IS HAPPENING ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
HOW MAY STOP IT WE DON'T
CONTINUE THAT APPROPRIATION AND
MAKE IT PERMANENT -- THEY WORK
THAT IS BEING DONE NOW IT'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
IN INCREASING OUT REACH THE
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURING THAT
MORE PEOPLE ARE COMING IN TO BE
SCREENED AND TREATED -- AND ALL
THE ALTHOUGH IT'S A VERY SMALL
INVESTMENT WE REALLY DON'T WANT
TO SEE.
A FOR THAT -- ROSHAN ON THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
PROGRAM SO THAT IS OUR US FOR
YOU TO THE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON SONYA PADDOCK
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WE WOULD SIMPLY NOTE
THAT THE THE PROJECT THE
PARTICULAR AMOUNT REQUESTED DOES
NOT.
HAVE AN ESPECIALLY ANALYTIC
BASIS IT'S SIMPLY TRYING TO
CONTINUE THE ONGOING
APPROPRIATION FROM LAST YEAR AND
THE AMOUNT TO ACTUALLY.
TRY TO HAUL TO REVERSE TRENDS IN
S. T. D. -- TRANSMISSION RATES
IS UNKNOWN -- I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IN THE SENATE HEARING LAST
WEEK SENATOR PAN REQUESTED THAT
OUR OFFICE WORK WITH FINANCE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH -- TO
TRY TO COME UP WITH WHAT THE THE
NUMBER THE AMOUNT WOULD BE TO
TRY TO HALT AND REVERSE THIS
TREND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT'S FEASIBLE BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET BUT I'VE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH -- OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE'LL.
WE'LL SEE WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
AND BE SURE TO KEEP.
YOU IN THE THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE UPDATED AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT A DOUBT IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT -- IT'S ALSO IT IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IT IS AN EQUITY ISSUE.
AND IF WE DON'T DO THE THE
IMPACT ANALYSIS BEING REQUESTED
THEY WILL NEVER KNOW.
WHERE THE POINT IS WHERE WE CAN
REALLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON THIS --
NEXT WITNESS.
ALRIGHT LET'S HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC THEN.
KERN HERE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION -- TWICE IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ATTIC ADVOCATED WITH OUR
PARTNERS ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH.
TO GET ADDITIONAL ONE TIME ONLY
FUNDS FOR THE STD BUDGET --
APPROVED IN THE BUDGET FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TWO
MILLION LAST YEAR IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN REFERENCED -- IT'S NEVER
ENOUGH -- I APPRECIATE LEADS
ANALYST COMMENT ABOUT HOW HOW
MUCH DO WE NEED IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE NEED TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING NOW SO ANY MONEY
PUT INTO LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE IS
GOING TO BE A BENEFIT.
I'M WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THIS
MORE NEXT WEEK I KNOW IT'S ON
THE ON THE AGENDA FOR NEXT WEEK
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT WE APPLY
THE GOVERNOR. FOR CONTINUING THE
FUNDING WE HAVE FOUGHT VERY HARD
TO GET ON GOING FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN THE LAST THREE
BUDGETS AND WERE UNSUCCESSFUL IN
THAT REGARD.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
THE NEED TO CARRY OVER THIS
FUNDING DOCTOR SHOPPERS AS
INDICATED BEFORE WE NEED TO PAY
FOR ON GOING COST LIKE STAFFING
AND ONE ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING WE
CAN'T DO THAT.
WE'LL TALK MORE NEXT WEEK WE
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
PRESENTATION NEXT WEEK THE
PROPOSAL WILL BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT -- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE
GIVENS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OR PLEASED TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AD
BUDGET FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING AND WE RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULTY WITH ONE TIME FANS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH ONE TIME
FUNDS WE DO ONE TIME INVESTMENT
SO COULD BE A AND MASS THAT
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN BUT IT.
CAN'T BE DEDICATED TO THINGS
LIKE STAFFING AND BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THOSE FUNDING SO THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WE DO HAVE
THE MANDATE TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
STDS BEING ONE OF THEM ONLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A HUGE
ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ADDITIONAL FUNDING FAMILY
JUST TO S. T. SPECIFICALLY BUT
INTER INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
NECESSARY AND SO WE APPRECIATE.
THIS ONGOING INVESTMENT BUT
DEFINITELY OPEN A CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT MORE NEEDED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT IS CLEAR TWO MILLION JUST IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT ENOUGH.
AND I THINK THAT ONCE WE WE HAVE
THE IMPACT REPORT WE CAN COME
CLOSER TO A NUMBER THAT WILL
REALLY HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO DO
SOMETHING MORE IMPACTFUL.
SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION -- COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE THE ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
PROGRAM GRANT AWARDS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON BRAIN
HEALTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS MONICA BROTHER SOME THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FROM THE CENTER
FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AS HE PH --
THIS PROPOSAL REALLY IS
HIGHLIGHTING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OF AN INCREASE OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
THE REGIONAL PROPOSAL JUST TO
KIND OF CLARIFY THERE'S A MAY
REVISE SUGGESTS IS BEING
PROCESSED RIGHT NOW BUT THE
REGION A PROPOSED TO HAD TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
AND THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND STATE
OPERATIONS THAT RECENTLY HAS
CHANGED TO TWO POINT OF FOUR
MILLION FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE AND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATE
OPERATIONS THE TWO POINT FOUR IS
TO SUPPORT KRANZ FOCUSED ON
WOMEN OF OLOR -- COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND WOMEN AFFECTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S.
AND ALSO TO REALLY LOOK AT
MOVING FORWARD CALL AREAS
PERTAINING TO CARE GIVING EARLY
DIAGNOSIS DETECTION AND
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE STATE OPERATIONS WILL
SUPPORT TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND CREATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TASK FORCE.
ON AL SUMMERS PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS AND ALSO SUPPORT --
TO STAFF TO REALLY DO A LOT OF
THE GRANT MONITORING A LOT OF
THE VALUATION REPORTING -- A
NUMBER AND A LOT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANTS THAT
REALLY TAKES PLACE WITH THE
GRANTS AND SUPPORTING THE TASK
FORCE -- SINCE JANUARY WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH AGENCY -- WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO REALLY TRY
TO CONCEPTUALIZE WHAT THIS IS
WHAT THE TASK FORCE GOING TO BE --
WITH THE FOCUSING ON WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
OF WE HOPEFULLY AT THIS POINT
ARE EXPLORING DIFFERENT WAYS TO
REALLY GET A SENSE OF WHAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS ARE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE TASK FORCE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE TO THE
SHEPHERD DEAN AND HELPING THE
DEPARTMENT CARRY ON A MAP.
HE ON WHAT SOME OF THESE
PRIORITY AREAS WILL BE FOR US
MOVING FORWARD.
SO THAT'S IN THE SUMMARY WHAT
THE PROPOSALS ABOUT.
THANKS THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
OUR OFFICE IS REVIEWED -- THE
PROPOSAL AND DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR CONCERNS THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GET PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BARBARA MARK
HAS AND I'M A BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL --
I LEFT I'VE I'VE ACTUALLY WORKED
IN PUBLIC HEALTH I RETIRED EARLY
TO TAKE CARE OF MY MOTHER.
WHO DIED FROM ALZHEIMER'S LAST
YEAR?
AND SO PROGRAMS ADDRESSING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND WOMEN IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SO WE HOPE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
SUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT INTERVENTIONS AND
STRATEGIES ARE AVAILABLE TO
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES LIKE
MINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR I'M
SUSAN TO MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL --
THE BUDGET PIECE THAT THE
RESEARCH PIECES SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON WOMEN IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND EQUALLY IMPORTANT THAT WERE --
LOOKING AT LOCAL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT STATE OPERATIONS
DOLLARS TO BUILD UP OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU WILL HEAR MORE FROM THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION NEXT
WEEK THERE'S A STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE ROLE AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT ALSO.
HI MARK WHITE VOLUNTEER THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION MY WIFE
DIED TWO DAYS BEFORE
THANKSGIVING LAST YEAR.
REASON WHY I'M SO REALLY
INTERESTED IN IN IN THIS IS I'VE
GOT TWO DAUGHTERS AND FIVE GRAND
KIDS.
AND THEY ARE IN THE SITES FOR
ALZHEIMER'S AND I DON'T WANT TO
SEE HIM HAVE IT I DON'T WANT TO
SEE IF YOUR FOLKS HAVE IT.
PLEASE HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITH THE
BUDGET TO PREVENT THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DAVID GINSBURG AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR ALZHEIMER'S -- IN
THAT MY MOTHER IN LAW RECENTLY
PASSED FROM THE DISEASE I HAD A
CAREER IN PUBLIC HEALTH --
WORKED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH FOR NINETEEN YEARS -- AND
AM VERY EXCITED TO SEE THAT ON
FINALLY THERE'S FUNDING THAT'S
GOING INTO SUPPORT THIS AND THAT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
STICKING LEADERSHIP ON THIS --
AND THAT YOU KNOW IT BEING THE
SIX LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE NEED TO THE
RESEARCH IS GOOD BUT WE NEED TO
LOOK FURTHER.
THANK YOU I AGREE.
MADAM CHAIRMAN HOWARD POSENER
VOLUNTEER WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION.
MY IMMEDIATE FAMILY HAS BEEN
VERY HARD HIT BY THIS DISEASE I
THINK.
I'M AT AN AGE WHERE IF THERE IS
A BREAKTHROUGH PERHAPS IT'S TOO
LATE FOR ME BUT I HAVE A
DAUGHTER HAVE. FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND I WORRY ABOUT
THEM.
INHERITING THE GENE FOR THIS
EVERY DAY SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE STATE CAN HELP WITH RESEARCH
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IMPACTS
WOMEN AND PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR DISPROPORTIONATELY.
SO WE FIND THAT THIS PROPOSALS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS EQUITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION I THANK THE
VOLUNTEERS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT WE DO NEED
TO DO SO MUCH MORE.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT AGE --
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT ALL OF US
WITH THEIR TO FAXES PERSONALLY
OR TO FIX OUR FAMILIES AND
WANTED FOLKS ARE FAMILIES IT'S
AFFECTING US.
AND WE DO NEED TO DO MORE I I
APPRECIATE TO THE THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION ON THIS AND HIS.
APPOINTMENT OF MARIA SHRIVER
ALSO I THINK THAT -- ONE MORE
TENSION IS GIVEN TO A PROGRAM
SUCH AS THIS.
WE CAN EXPECT MORE.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
AND I'M ALSO LOOKING FOR THE
STOCK QUOTE STOCKHOLDERS TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- PROPOSAL NEXT
WEEK THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR CHILDHOOD LEAD
POISONING PREVENTION PROGRAM
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION. FOR THE RECORD
MONICA MORALIS CITY PH CENTER
FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
OCCURRING -- DEAN CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO THIS IS A BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
A FOUR YEAR PROPOSAL TOTALING
TWENTY SIX FOUR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IT REALLY IS AN INITIATIVE TO
UPDATE OUR EIGHTEEN LEAD.
TO DATA SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN
THE DEPARTMENT -- THE FIRST YEAR
WERE REQUESTING EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND
A NINE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIVE POINT
NINE MILLION FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THEN THREE POINT
FOUR ONGOING -- MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THE SCENE INTO A LOT OF
THE CHANGES IN NEW MANDATES
RELATED TO LEAD.
AND WE'RE DOING A DECENT JOB IN
THE DEPARTMENT I WAS SAY IN
TERMS OF REALLY TRYING TO KEEP
UP WITH THE NUMBER OF CHANGES
AND THE NEW -- REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THE PART OF THAT
ALSO MEANS THAT WE RELY ON OUR
SYSTEMS TO REALLY PROVIDE US
WITH THE REPORTING TECHNOLOGIES
AND CAPABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER SOME BASIC QUESTIONS LIKE
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN BEING
SERVED FOR EXAMPLE AND SO FORTH
AND STAKEHOLDERS SAID THAT WE
WORK WITH.
IN LABORATORY CENTER THAT ARE
REPORTING INTO OUR SYSTEM.
SO FOR US THIS IS AN ONGOING --
PROPOSAL THAT WE STARTED LAST
YEAR WE GOT A OF B. C. P.
APPROVED TO START THE PELL
PROCESSES AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
THIS IS A CONTINUATION FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH STAGE THREE
AND FOUR OF THE PROCESSES.
OF IN NOT ONLY IMPACTS OBVIOUSLY
CITY P. H. WE WORK WITH ABOUT
FIFTY ONE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT WE CONTRACT
WITH TO PROVIDE A LOT OF THE
LEAD.
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
INVESTIGATIONS AND THEY RELY ON
THE SYSTEM AS WELL.
CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE A VERY
SOPHISTICATED SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE
WERE YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONNECT WHEN YOU'RE.
DOING FIELD WORK AT HOME WHERE
YOU'RE DOCUMENTING SOME OF THE
CASE MANAGEMENT OR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
INVESTIGATIONS INTO LIKE A
TABLET FOR EXAMPLE ARE.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO INTO
THIS YOU KNOW HAVE A PAPER
PROCESSING METHOD THAT WE'RE
STILL USING AND SO OUR GOAL
REALLY WITH THE SYSTEM IS TO TRY
TO MOVE FORWARD IN ADVANCE.
ARE REPORTING CASE MANAGEMENT
CAPABILITIES AND MOST OF PARTY
CATCH UP TO IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF
OUR AUTOMATED -- DATA SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS PROPOSES ABOUT -- MY
COLLEAGUE GERRY CAN GIVE MORE
EXAMPLES TO ON THE A. T. STEP.
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR US VERY
GOOD THANK YOU -- STE SO THIS IS
AN I. T. SYSTEM AND WE'RE
REPLACING AN EXISTING AGING
SYSTEM -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING AND
PLANNING THIS PROJECT FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF AND WE HAVE AT LEAST
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS OF PLANNING
BEFORE WERE ACTUALLY COULD GO
INTO HAVE APPROVAL FOR
DEVELOPMENT WE FEEL LIKE WE'VE
INVESTED A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT IN.
IN IDENTIFYING WHAT WHAT --
BUSINESS REQUIREMENTS WE NEED ON
THE OUTCOME FROM THE SYSTEM.
WE FEEL THAT THE REQUEST OF THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET TODAY IS IS VERY
REALISTIC AND IS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE FOR THE TOTAL COST
OF THIS PROJECT OVER THE THE
THREE TO FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
WE FEEL THE PROJECT HAS A HIGH
RATE OF SUCCESS BECAUSE WE HAVE
LEARNED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND WE ARE DOING FOR THIS
PROJECT.
RE USING SOFTWARE THAT WE
CURRENTLY OWN PLATFORMS OF
SOFTWARE THAT -- LIKE G. I. S.
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE IN PRODUCTION TODAY AND
SO WE'RE RECONFIGURING THOSE AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF INTERNAL SKILLS.
THAT LEAD TO LOWERING THE RISK
OF FAILURE INCREASING THAT THE
RISK FOR SUCCESS.
THE PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION
SCHEDULE IS HIGHLY TUNED AROUND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE
WOULD -- AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THAT IT GETS --
APPROVED IN THAT WAY SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DELAYS AND THE THE
STAFF HIRING THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
AND THE ACTUAL ONGOING
CONTINUITY OF CONTRACTS BETWEEN
FISCAL YEARS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S HEAR THE CONCERNS OKAY --
SO YOU PICK FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND WE DO NOT PARTICULARLY HAVE
ANY CONCERNS ABOUT THE MERITS OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE DON'T DISAGREE
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT I. T.
SYSTEM -- AS WAS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA OUR OUR OFFICE DID NOTE
THAT THERE WERE.
AS SEVEN DIFFERENT PROPOSALS --
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
REQUEST FULL IT PROJECT FUNDING
BEFORE THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE PROCESS IS COMPLETE.
THE ONE OF THE PURPOSES OF THE
HELL PROCESS WHEN IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED WAS TO GIVE THE BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE -- MORE INFORMATION
SO THAT THEY WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE ABOUT TO THE THE
ACTUAL COST OF IT PROJECTS AND
ON TO THE THE ASSOCIATED
TIMELINES WITH THE PROJECTS.
THIS PARTICULAR REQUEST OF FOR
FUNDING IS -- REQUESTING THE
FULL FULL EIGHTY PROJECT FUNDING
FOR IMPLEMENTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION -- BEFORE THE
THAT STAGES THREE AND FOUR OF
THE PALO PROCESS.
IS COMPLETE AND WHILE THE THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT MAY VERY WELL
KEEP.
ON SCHEDULE AND WITHIN COST WE
DO RAISE SOME CONCERNS JUST
ABOUT HOW THIS AFFECTS THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT OF IT PROJECTS NOT
ONLY FOR THIS PROJECT BUT OR
THE OTHER.
PROJECTS THAT HAVE A SIMILAR
APPROACH IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
SO WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND IS --
ONE OF TWO THINGS EITHER
APPROVING A SINGLE YEAR FUNDING
pBACK NEXT YEAR AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- IN ORDER TO ADD
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- WHERE WE'RE
BY FUNDING WOULD BE CONTINGENT
ON -- APPROVAL OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE DOCUMENTS BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY --
WITH NOTIFICATION TO THE
APPROPRIATE DEPARTMENTS AS WELL
AS TO THE LEGISLATURE -- FOR ITS
APPROVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS -- ROB TROJAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALTHOUGH WE DEFINITELY KNOWLEDGE
LA THOSE CONCERNS -- THERE HAVE
BEEN RECENT.
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED
BY PUBLIC HEALTH AND FOR EXAMPLE
THE CANNABIS LICENSING SYSTEM SO
THEY HAVE THE CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE AROUND THAT.
THAT WOULD HELP DEVELOP THE
PROPER REASONABLE ESTIMATES AND
SO WE WOULD AGREE WITH AND THE
CURRENT ESTIMATES THAT THEY HAVE.
AND THEN THERE WOULD BE SOME
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES WITH
AWARDING CONTRACT THE FULL
FUNDING.
WAS NOT -- WAS NOT APPROVED IN
THE BUDGET BECAUSE THEY WILL BE --
FOR CARRYING THIS -- WHICH WE
COMING UP IN OCTOBER IN THE FALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOW GOING BACK TO THE IS SAYING
NO PUBLIC COMMENT -- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THEN GO BACK TO THE
CONCERN FROM THE LA -- IT'S A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN -- IS THERE A
IT'S NOT THAT THE ART THAT I HAD
ONLY CONSIDERED THE ONE YOU'RE
FUNDING BUT I THINK HAVING THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN THE
PRODUCT AND THE PROJECT.
ALONG WITH THE FUNDING OF WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT FEEL
ABOUT THAT OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WELL OUR OUR CONCERN WOULD BE
ANY DISRUPTION TO THE FLOW OF
THE PROJECT I MEAN WE HAVE SPENT
OVER TWO YEARS PLANNING WE HAVE
FOUR DIFFERENT CONTRACTS MULTI
YEAR CONTRACT -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT AT THE END OF THE POWER
PROCESS WHICH IS -- FINAL
APPROVAL BY THE PARTNER
TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE TWO ONGOING
OVERSIGHT REPORTAGE THAT OUR
PUBLIC AND THAT CONTINUALLY
MONTH AFTER MONTH MONITOR THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF THE
PROJECT.
SO HAVING TO COME BACK EVERY
YEAR POTENTIALLY WITH ANOTHER
VCP WOULD MEAN WE WOULD HAVE TO
WRITE A B. C. P. TODAY FOR NEXT
YEAR TO ENSURE WE HAVE NO LAPSE.
AND IN SOME CASES A DEPENDING ON
THE CONTRACT COULD BE RIGHT A
MULTI YEAR CONTRACT WITHOUT
HAPPENED WHEN NOT HAVING
GUARANTEED FUNDING IT INTRODUCES
A FEW ISSUES OF THE FLOW OF THE
PROJECT.
THE LAST THING WE'D EVER WANT IS
NOT TO BE ABLE HIGHER OUR STAFF
FULL TIME RATHER THAN LIMIT TO
TERM WHO'D WANT TO BREAK IN A
CONTRACT WHERE WE WOULD HAVE TO
POTENTIALLY GO OUT TO BID AGAIN
AND HIGHER DIFFERENT VENDOR. TO
WORK THOSE THINGS COULD CAUSE
THE DESTRUCTION THAT WERE WERE A
TOTAL OF A AGREEMENT ALIGNMENT
WITH TRANSPARENCY.
A WHATEVER -- IT TAKES TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS IT THAT WE'RE
TRANSPARENT AND WE MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISIONS.
BUT KNOWING HOW HEALTH PRIOR
PROJECTS GO THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF OVERSIGHT
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND EVEN FINANCE ON A REGULAR
BASIS ON THE SUCCESS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT EFFORT OF A PROJECT.
SO PALM I'M I I'D NOT SURE THAT
BRING IT BACK THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY YEAR IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
TO BE DONE IS A LOT OF EFFORT
AND WORK TO PUT A BGP THROUGH
OUR OUR COME BACK AROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S THAT IT'S PICKED
A FULL.
AND WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD TRACK
RECORD AND WE'RE BUILDING ON
KNOWN.
PLATFORMS -- IF THIS WAS
SOMETHING BRAND NEW I WOULD
COULD BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT BUT
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT WE'VE
INVEST A LOT OF TIME TO ENSURE
ITS SUCCESS.
IT IT AS WAS NOTED IN THE HELP
PROCESS THE LAST. TWO STAGES
HAVE NOT BEEN COMPLETED.
I MEAN THE WHOLE PURPOSES FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY -- AND I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE ALEJO.
EXPRESSING THE CONCERNS IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT THE LEAD.
TESTING IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR CHILDREN.
I THINK THEY HAVE TO BE TESTED
TWICE AND THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
OTHER DEPARTMENT THE NEEDS -- TO
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICES THANK
YOU -- IF THE COMMUNICATION
ISN'T.
OPEN BETWEEN THE TWO I CAN TELL
YOU THAT RECENTLY THERE WAS A
HEARING ON THIS.
AND TO SEE THAT MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN ARE FALLING.
BETWEEN THE CRACKS AND IT'S A
SERIOUS PROBLEM -- BECAUSE THE
RESULTS ARE DEVASTATING I KNOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN I. T.
SYSTEM.
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
CHILDREN AND IF WE DON'T DO THAT
LET TESTING ON THE CHILDREN WE
HAVE SOME MORE CAKE.
PROCESS OF KEEPING TRACK.
IT IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM -- BUT I
APPRECIATE LA OWES -- CONCERN
AND THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
WITH US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR MADAM CHAIR JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS UP ON THAT SO.
YOU'RE INTO THE DIFFERENT STAGES
AND SO LAST TWO STAGES NOW THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO COMPLETE OF AN
ONGOING PROJECT.
FOR SEVERAL DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
NAM BUDGET CYCLES.
WHAT THIS -- THAT THE PAGE ROOM
RIGHT NOW IS THAT -- IS THEY
CALL THE PAL PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE ON IT THE IT'S IN FOUR
PHASES AND AT THE END YOUR
GIVING AUTHORITY BY DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AN AGENCY. TO AWARD
CONTRACTS AND MOVE FOR TO
DEVELOPMENT SO WE HAVE A
STARTING DEVELOPING YET WE'RE
JUST LINING UP THE DIFFERENT
CONTRACTS AND THE WORK EFFORT
THAT WE NEED. TO GET READY AND
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
OVERSIGHT PROCESS BY APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE. TEN
MANAGEMENT PLAN SEARCH FOR
CONTRACT AND STATE STREE IS
FAIRLY EXTENSIVE WE'VE JUST
FINISHED AGE THREE I'M RUNNING
IT THROUGH OUR DEPARTMENT FOR
APPROVAL.
AND THEN WE WOULD MOVE IN THE
STATE FOR WHICH WOULD WE COULD
RELEASE THE CONTRACT.
AND GET THE RESPONSES BACK AND
THEN WE WOULD DEPEND ON THE
APARTMENT TECHNOLOGY TO GIVE US
AUTHORITY TO AWARD THE CONTRACT.
THEN WE COULD START DEVELOPMENT
SO YOU'RE RIGHT WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED THE FULL POWER PROCESS
YET BUT THE ACTUAL DOLLARS AND
RECOMMENDATION AND STAFFING WAS
DONE IN THE STAGE TO WHICH WAS
FULLY APPROVED AND SUPPORTS THE
BUDGET ACTION -- WE WILL BE
GETTING APPROVAL.
IN THE MIDDLE OF NEXT OF COUNTY
OR AT THE END OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR. TWO OF STATE FOR THAT'S
FOR WE THINK WE ARE AND WE WOULD
NOT WANT ANY DELAYS AT THAT
POINT -- WE WOULD WANT TO BE
ABLE TO AWARD A CONTRACT AND GET
STARTED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE -- IS SOMETHING IF IF
THERE IS GOING TO BE.
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A COMPLETE
APPROVAL I THINK THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WILL BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT -- PERHAPS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALEJO AND
STAFF CAN CAN WORK ON IF I MAY
MADAM CHAIR YES -- I THINK ONE
OF THE TRICKY THINGS ABOUT THIS
IS THAT THE PROPOSAL IS IS
ESSENTIALLY REQUESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GRANT IT'S APPROVAL
AND FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT
BEFORE.
IT HAS THE BENEFIT OF SEEING THE
FINALIZED PAL DOCUMENTS THE WAY
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THE ADMINISTRATION --
THEY'LL GET TO SEE THOSE
DOCUMENTS BEFORE THEY GIVE THEIR
FINAL APPROVAL AND IN THIS CASE
THEY'RE REQUESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DO SO WITHOUT THAT
BENEFIT SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE WELCOME.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM EXPANSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M LESS LIKE THE CHIEF OF THE
AND C. H. TO VISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I WILL BE GOING OVER
THE TWO PC PCH.
IN THE B. I. H. THAT THE WE ARE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WE KNOW
IS IN SUPPORT OF AND IT ALSO
ALIGNS WITH WOMEN AND CHILDREN'S
ISSUES.
UNLESS THE GAFFNEY I'M THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
CENTER FOR FAMILY HEALTH.
AS WE KNOW DECADES OF RESEARCH
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD OPEN VISITING
SHOW THAT HOME VISITS BY A
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL DURING
PREGNANCY AND IN THE FIRST YEARS
OF LIFE IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
HOME VISITING HAVE BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO LOWER RATES OF
CHILDHOOD INJURY CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
AND SMOKING DURING PREGNANCY
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME IMPROVING
RATES OF IMMUNIZATION BREAST
FEEDING RATES AND LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT.
WE KNOW THAT HOME VISITING AS
WELL POISED TO ASSIST PARENTS IN
LEARNING HOW TO PROVIDE THEIR
CHILDREN WITH A STRONG START TO
SAFE STABLE AND NURTURING
ENVIRONMENTS.
CURRENTLY THROUGH FEDERAL
FUNDING CH P. C. H. B. T. SERVES
PREGNANT AND NEARLY PARENTING
FAMILIES AND TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES USING THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIPS AND FAMILY AND
HEALTHY FAMILIES AMERICA.
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
MODELS THE PROGRAMS MEET THE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES WHO HAVE ONE
OR MORE RISK FACTORS INCLUDING
INADEQUATE INCOME AND STABLE
HOUSING EDUCATION LESS THAN
TWELVE YEARS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND DEPRESSION AND MENTAL
ILLNESS IN STATE FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE MADE
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND HOME VISITS
AND SERVED NEARLY THREE THOUSAND
MOMS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THIRTEEN POSITIONS AND
TWENTY THREE MILLION IN STATE
GENERAL FUNDS TWENTY ONE
ENVELOPE FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AND TWO MILLION STATE OPERATIONS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
ANNUALLY AND THERE AFTER TO
EXPAND OUR CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAM.
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL DEVELOP IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS A
SYSTEMATIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
COMPREHENSIVE DOES SCISSION
MAKING APPROACH. TO EVALUATE AND
SELECT A NEW MODEL AND WHERE
BASS TO EXPAND OUR HOME VISITING
PROGRAM WITH A FOCUS ON LOW
INCOME.
AND YOUNG MOTHERS EXPANDING OUR
HOME VISITING EFFORTS INTO OTHER
COUNTIES AND EXPLORING THE
ADOPTION OF ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE
BASED MODELS WILL ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND RESILIENCY NEEDS.
OF MORE MORE VULNERABLE FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA MATCH.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD A A
QUESTION THAT THAT -- THAT WE
WANT TO CLARIFY FOR YOU ALL.
YOU WANTED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE DOING IN YOUR
ONE TWO AND THREE AND WE WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT IN YEAR ONE WE WILL
BE EXPANDING.
OUR CURRENT SITES.
THAT ARE SERVING OUR HOME THAT
ARE THAT ARE THAT ARE CARRYING
OUT HOME VISITING PROGRAMS.
AND IN YOUR TO WE WILL EXPAND
INTO NEW COUNTIES WITH OUR
CURRENT AND IF PM HFA MODELS.
AND THEN IN YEAR THREE WE WILL
EXPAND INTO IMPLEMENTING OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED MODELS.
WE THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT
ASKING WHETHER OR NOT ALL OF
THESE CAN OVERLAP IN YEAR.
ONE AND WHILE THE THREE
ACTIVITIES DON'T NECESSARILY
OVERLAP THE ACTUAL WORK LEADING
UP TO THE IMPLEMENTATION WILL
OVERLAP IN YEAR.
ONE IN THE FIRST YEAR WE WILL
LOOKS WE WILL BE EXPANDING
PARTICIPATION AT THE EXISTING C.
H. B. P. SITES AS I MENTIONED
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
DEVELOPING AND WRITING THE
FUNDING MECHANISMS TO EXPAND TO
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES IN YOUR TO
IN ADDITION THROUGHOUT YOUR ONE
WE WILL BE.
WORKING WITH IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
PROTECTIONS ON A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND THE EVALUATION OF
HOME VISITING MODELS AND THE
VARIOUS HOME VISITING MODELS
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE WHICH NEW
MODEL TO SUPPORT TO SUPPORT IN
YEAR.
THREE GIVEN ALL THE NEW
INVESTMENTS IN HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN LAUNCH
SINCE WE STARTED OUR PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWELVE WE FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CURRENT
NEEDS ARE AND WHERE THE CURRENT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE.
AND WHAT MODELS ARE BEST SUITED
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
I'M A FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MICHELLE
GIVENS AT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND FOR FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING PROGRAM
AND FOR THE EXPANSION WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED MODELS OUT THERE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NOT MAXIMIZING.
THE COULD BE WORKING AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME MODELS THAT
ARE VERY RIGOROUS THE ONLY ALLOW
FOR A VERY SMALL AND THAT
POPULATION THAT COULD BE
INVOLVED.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT I HAD HOUSEHOLDS
WITH CHILDREN THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS WE RECOGNIZE
IMPACTS OF THINGS LIKE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO TAYLOR -- MODELS BASED
ON THE POPULATIONS OF OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ON THE OTHER THING I
WOULD JUST MENTION AS IN REGARDS
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S TIMELINE
WE DON'T HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT
OTHER TO THAN TO SAY THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN A DISCUSSION.
ABOUT WHETHER THAT TIMELINE MAKE
SENSE OR WHETHER THERE'S
EXPANSIONS THAT COULD BE
HAPPENING SOONER OR ON A
DIFFERENT TIME LINE AND SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO ENGAGE FURTHER ON THAT
THANK YOU.
TELL US YOUR NAME AND YOUR IS --
ORGANIZATION AGAIN PLEASE --
MICHELLE GIBBONS WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE SUPPORT BOTH
THE FUNDING AS WELL AS THE
EXPANSION OF THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM THANKS.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PANDA THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I CAN LOS WITH REPRESENTING
CHILDREN NOW AND I SAY THAT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR
FOR PROPOSING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THAT.
C. H. P. P. PROGRAM AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT TO
EXPAND BEYOND THE TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES IN THE EXISTING.
I'M TO EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS
HOME VISITING CURRENTLY REACHES
ABOUT 2% OF CALIFORNIA BABIES
BUT WE KNOW THAT AS MANY AS 60%.
I'M COULD BENEFIT FROM THE ASSN
SEVEN REALLY TO ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY GET THESE PROGRAMS
OUT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
CHILDREN NOW.
AVERAGES -- THAT WE SUPPORT
IMMEDIATELY AND WITHOUT FURTHER
STUDY THE ADOPTION OF EXISTING
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAM MODELS THAT ARE MEETING
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
MATERNAL INFANT AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD HOME VISITING CRITERIA
AS A LIST OF MODELS ALLOWABLE
UNDER SIEGE V. P..
AND THAT WE ESTABLISH A PROCESS
TO ISSUE CONTRACTS EXISTING AND
NEW COUNTIES NO LATER THAN
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS TO ENSURE
THAT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS THE FUNDS --
AND THAT WE ASSESS AS STEPS TO
SET ASIDE NOT TO EXCEED TWENTY
FIVE ART BY PERCENT OF THE
EXISTING FUNDS. TO SUPPORT LOCAL
INNOVATIONS TO PROMISING AREN'T
PROGRAMS FOR NEW MODELS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING ON BEHALF
OF THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
WE ARE VERY EXCITED TO SEE THE
EXPANSION OF SIEGE V. P. THIS
YEAR AND OF P. IS ONE OF THE
EXISTING MODELS -- WE ALSO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE CONCEPT OF
LOOKING AT THE BESTDATA IN
ORDER TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
POPULATIONS -- BENEFIT BEST FROM
WHICH TYPE OF HOME VISITING
MODELS UP LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND WITH
DPH AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIGURING OUT WHAT.
POPULATIONS WOULD BE BEST SERVED
BY DIFFERENT MODELS WE HOPE TO
BE CONSIDERED AND THAT.
ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE EXPLANATION OF HOW THE
GROWTH WOULD HAPPEN OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS SO WILL
CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS SOME ROOM FOR GROWTH AND
EXPANSION.
PARTICULARLY IN A COUPLE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT AND IF PIECE
SERVES WHERE WE'VE HAD TO CAP OR
SERVICES DUE TO COST OF LIVING
INCREASES NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
COMMENSURATE.
WITH THE EXISTING FUNDING THAT
WE GET SO WE APPRECIATE THIS
BUDGET ITEM AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- OCCURS ON BEHALF OF
THE MARCH DOWN THE SUPPORT GROUP
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I'M SURE THANK YOU AND AND TO
ALLOW VERY LITTLE ONE OF THE
PUBLIC SPEAKER AS FAR AS A
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
IS THAT WITHIN THE PLAN OR OR
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT WORKING OUT
WITHIN THE SOME BUDGET REQUESTS.
CURRENTLY WE WE FIND.
THAT TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
DRIVING THE MICROPHONE CLOSE
FROM SORRY CURRENTLY THERE IS
DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO THE
HOME VISITING PROGRAM -- THAT
THE TRIBES ARE IMPLEMENTING AND
I THINK THAT WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB REACHING OUT TO THEM AND
UNDERSTANDING HOW THEIR MODELS
ARE WORKING AND HOW THIS NEW.
NEW.
OPPORTUNITY CAN HELP MEET THE
NEEDS THAT THAT MIGHT NOT BE
CURRENTLY MATT.
SO SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT ARE BEING USE ARE BEING
PROPOSED.
ARE THOSE BEST PRACTICES --
BEING USED WITHIN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I WE
HAVE TITLE FIVE FUNDING OUR OUR
BLOCK GRANT FUNDS GO TO SUPPORT
HOME VISITING WITHIN THE TRIBES
AND I KNOW THAT THEY ARE WORKING
ON A JOHN HOPKINS EVIDENCE BASED
MODEL.
BUT WE WE CAN CERTAINLY BE
CIRCLING BACK AROUND TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT KIND OF
OUTCOMES ARE GIVEN GETTING
JUXTAPOSED TO THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE SEEING WITH AND IF PM HFA
MODELS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK
GETTING A REPORT -- BASED ON
THAT AS FAR AS THE TROUBLE
COMMUNITIES AND HOW BEST
PRACTICES ARE BEING USED THEIR
ALSO BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE
BEING PRESENTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S CONSISTENCY -- OUT
THERE AS FAR AS MAKING SURE THAT
ALL ARE BEING SERVED UP UNDER
THE STYLUS.
THANK YOU MISTER ABBAS.
THE COUNTY IS BEING SERVE THE
TWENTY THREE COUNTIES BEING
SERVED -- IT JUST SO HAPPENS OF
THREE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
ARE ALL FROM SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND THAT IS NOT ONE OF
THE COUNTIES -- IN THE EXPANSION.
THE WORD IS SANDRA DINO -- FOR
SAN BERNADINO ABSOLUTELY SAMBAR
MEDINA WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THESE FUNDS
WE WE'D WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT HOLES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT.
NOT ONLY HAS FIRST FIVE STEPPED
UP TO FIND HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE CURRENT CAL WORKS
EXPANSION HAS HAS A FORTY
COUNTIES WITH ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
TO DO HOME VISITING.
SO THAT'S WHY THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE WHERE
HAVE OTHERS PICKED UP AND FUNDED
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS.
AND WILL WHO HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND SO THAT'S OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY IDENTIFY THOSE
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE FUNDING
FOR HOME VISITING.
AND MAYBE NOT HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS
TO REACH ALL THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE IN NEED.
WHEN I SEE?
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO.
INCLUDED IN THE COUNTIES THAT
OUR AT THAT ARE RECEIVING -- THE
HOME VISITING -- I CAN'T IMAGINE.
THAT THEY DON'T ALSO HAVE THE
FIRST FIVE AND THE OTHERS.
COULD.
PROVIDE SOME OF THAT SERVICE SO
IT IS A GREAT CONCERN THAT THE
LARGEST COUNTY.
IN THE STATE.
WOULD NOT BE INCLUDED.
I RECOGNIZE IT RIVERSIDE IN FROM
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS ON THE LIST
BUT NONE THE LESS -- KNOWING HOW
THE COUNTY USE ARE SELECTED AND
GOING BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTION.
REGARDING HOW THE SELECTIONS.
ARE MADE ON INVEST MODELS BEING
USED AT EACH.
ONE I THINK IS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
DO YOU HAVE CRITERIA.
THAT WILL BE USED TO YOU HAVE
THE LIST OF CRITERIA THAT WILL
BE USED IN DETERMINING WHAT
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE
INCLUDED.
THAT WILL EXPANSION STATEMENT
THAT WILL HAPPEN DURING YOUR ONE
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEEDS WE
WANT IT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE ARE GOING TO EMBARK ON WITH
THESE WITH THIS WITH THESE NEW
MONIES ARE REALLY GOING TO MEET
THE NEEDS THAT ARE NOT BEING MET
CURRENTLY SORE FUNDING CRITERION
WHO WERE GOING TO BE FUNDING
REALLY IS GOING TO BE DICTATED
THROUGH THIS NEEDS ASSESSMENT
PROCESS.
AND WE WANT TO SEEK INPUT FROM
THE COUNTIES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT FUNDING
CRITERIA NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE
AND WE WILL BE PUTTING TOGETHER
A METHODOLOGY THAT WILL THAT WE
WILL SEEK INPUT ON AND APPROVAL
[inaudible]
FOR IT.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT YOU HAVE AN
IDEA ON WHAT IS GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
WE CURRENTLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WOMEN ARE WHAT WHAT WOMEN
ARE CURRENTLY IN HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS WHERE THE PSYCHO SOCIAL
ISSUES ARE OCCURRING IN IN WHICH
NEIGHBORHOODS.
ARE THE COUNTIES LIKE IN LA ABLE
TO REACH THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
WITH THE HOME VISITING PROGRAM.
DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT.
NURSE OR HOME VISITOR.
IN THE RIGHT LOCATION TO DELIVER
THE SERVICES SO WE'VE GOT WE
HAVE A A ROBUST NEEDS ASSESSMENT
THAT WE WANT TO IMPLEMENT TO
REALLY GET A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS WHAT IS
BEING CURRENTLY CARRIED OUT.
AND WHO ISN'T BEING LEFT BEHIND
[inaudible]
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU GOING?
TO WHAT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
OFTEN COMES UP IS THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVE SOME COUNTIES ARE SOME
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE BETTER AT WRITING
PROPOSALS KLAY AND IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DETERMINE THE NEEDS OF
A COMMUNITY.
AND YOU ASK THE THE COMMUNITY
WHAT ARE YOUR NEEDS IF THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT EVERYBODY
ELSE IS LOOKING AT THEY WON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
SAYING.
WHERE IS IF THERE IS A LIST
ALREADY OF WHAT IT IS YOU'RE
LOOKING -- FOR IT WOULD SEEM TO
ME THAT THE COUNTIES ARE THE
CITIES OR THE COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING LEFT OUT WOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THEY CAN
ASK.
OF THAT THEY CAN ASK FOR AND IF
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEING ASSESSED.
THEN THEY WON'T KNOW TO TELL YOU
ABOUT IT.
BUT THAT ALWAYS IS A A MAJOR
CONCERN.
SO WE PARTNER QUITE CLOSELY WITH
OUR MATERNAL CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT HEALTH DIRECTORS IN
EACH OF THE COUNTIES SO THEY
HAVE THEIR POLLS ON EXCUSE ME.
FOR INTERRUPTING IN EACH OF THE
COUNTIES THAT YOU ALREADY FUND
OR IN EACH OF THE COUNTIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE A
REGULAR READ -- ON GOING
DISCUSSION AND RELATIONSHIP WE
HAVE MONTHLY MEETINGS WE HAVE
BIANNUAL TODAY THREE DAY
MEETINGS WITH OUR LOCAL NCH
DIRECTORS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THEY ARE
COMPLETING A A TITLE FIVE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TO REALLY ASSESS THE
COMPREHENSIVELY ALL THE NEEDS OF
WOMEN'S CHILDREN USE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WITH SPECIAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS WITH IN THEIR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTION.
SO THEY'VE BEEN SPENDING A YEAR
LOOKING AT THE NEEDS WE ENVISION
THAT THE HOME VISITING PROGRAM
NEEDS ASSESSMENT WILL BE ON THE
HEELS OF THIS ROBUST NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
SO THEY HAVE THEIR POLLS ON
WHAT'S GOING ON AND HAVE THE
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND AND WE BELIEVE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM AND NOT JUST
STANDING BACK AT THE STATE AND
SAYING HERE'S YOU SHOW ME THAT
SHOW ME THE PAPER BUT REALLY
DIALOGUING AND HAVING IN PERSON
MEETINGS TO UNDERSTAND.
FACE TO FACE WHETHER THE NEEDS
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING WITHIN
YOUR COUNTIES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THE SERVICE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ABSOLUTE AND THAT FOR
THOSE FAMILIES THOSE MOTHERS WHO
HAVE THE HOME VISITS.
THEY AND THEIR CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT THAT'S RIGHT
BUT OF GREAT CONCERN.
ESPECIALLY IT JUST SO HAPPENS
THAT THE THREE OF US SITTING
HERE AT THE DICE ARE ALL FROM
SAMBAR TO DO YOU KNOW REPRESENT.
PARTS OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
AND TO KNOW THAT THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS.
WE'RE JUST ONE OF THE COUNTIES.
BUT WE HAVE MANY OTHERS WHO ARE
ALSO EXCLUDED.
MR ROMS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST GOING BACK TO THE THE DATA
COLLECTION AND REACHING OUT TO
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES I HEARD
THAT CORRECT RIGHT.
SO -- AND AND LOOKING AT THE
LIST OF THOSE THAT ARE READY --
ENGAGED IN AND SOME OF THESE
HOME VISITING MOM THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE.
DOES THE THE DATA TAKEN TO
COLLECTION URBAN SUBURBAN -- AS
FAR AS THOSE COUNTIES IN THE
SEPARATION OF THOSE -- AREAS
WHERE THEY'RE AT IT WELL AND IT
DOES YES SIR A COUNTY THE SIZE
OF SAN BENITO COUNTY.
DEALS WITH ALL THOSE RURAL
SUBURBAN AND URBAN -- ASK EVEN
OF ITS DESIGNATED URBAN COUNTY
BUT STILL THE NEED IS THERE.
SO IF ALL THAT DATA IS COMING IN
HOW THEN I MEAN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HOW
THEN DO YOU START TO LOOK AT
WHERE.
THAT MONEY IS STARTING TO GO OR
AS FAR AS THOSE THAT ARE GONNA
BE COMPETING.
HOW TO THE RIGHT FOR THAT GRANT
BASED ON THAT CRITERIA THAT'S
COMING IN AND IS THERE A
CRITERIA MODEL -- GIVEN TO THE
COUNTIES AHEAD OF TIME SO THEY
CAN START TO PLAN AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE PERFORMING.
IN AREAS THAT.
WILL BE SEEN -- POSSIBLE --
POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
GRANT MOVING FORWARD.
SO THERE'S THAT THE NF P. AND
HFA THEY HAVE MODEL CRITERIA
THAT THAT.
THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN IMPLEMENTED WILL
WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES THEIR
THEIR EVIDENCE BASED MODEL SO
THERE ARE SPECIFIC CRITERIA FOR
THE TWO MODELS THAT THAT WE
IMPLEMENT.
SO WE WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THE NEEDS OF THE POPULATION IN
ORDER TO UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE.
WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS OF
IMPLEMENTING OTHER MODELS THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT CRITERIA?
AND SO THAT THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE EMBARKING ON IN YOUR
ONE SO WHEN YOU'RE.
THREE WERE IMPLEMENTING A
DIFFERENT MODEL WITH A DIFFERENT
SET OF CRITERIA TO MEET AN AND
MATT NEED IN THE COMMUNITY. TO
MAKE SENSE.
YEAH BUT IS A SEPARATE IT
TOWARDS URBAN SUBURBAN ARE --
ROLE AS FAR AS THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AT THAT AND THE DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED OR HOW THOSE
GRANTS ARE COMING FORWARD.
INVEST MODELS USED IN THE THAT
KERR PARTICULAR SETTING.
I'M OR IS IT JUST.
IT'S BROUGHT IT'S BROUGHT IS BY
COUNTY WE WE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF KNOWING THE VET THE NEEDS OF
THE COUNTY.
WHETHER IT'S URBAN RURAL OR
POCKETS WITHIN IT WITH IN A CITY
IS UP TO THE M. C. H. DIRECTORS
AND WE LIE ON RELY ON THEM FOR
THEIR EXPERTISE TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND.
HOW BEST TO CARRY FORWARD
PROGRAMS AND SO USING THE LENS
OF OUR HOME VISITING MODEL?
WHAT MODELS THEN BECAUSE MODELS
HAVE CRITERIA WHAT CRITERIA THEN
DO WE WANT TO IMPLEMENT IN THE
COUNTIES TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET THE RESULTS THAT WE
WANT WITH THIS INVESTMENT?
THANK YOU. FOR THE TEST IT IS AN
IN IT AND WE WANT TO SPEND THE
TIME AND THE VERY THOUGHTFUL IN
THIS REVIEW SO THAT WE TRULY
UNDERSTAND WHO'S BEING LEFT
BEHIND BUT COUNTIES AREN'T BEING
FUNDED WHAT POPULATIONS ARE NOT
BEING FUNDED.
AND THEN DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT
MODELS IN PLACE THAT HAVE THE
CRITERION THE FIDELITY TO THE
MODEL TO CLOSE THE GAPS IN THOSE
NEEDS.
VETERAN COLLECTING DATA ON
DEMOGRAPHICS EIGHT ON CLIENTS
CORRECT CORRECT CURRENT.
SO AS PART OF THE TWO MODELS
THAT WE USE THAT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT FROM THER MODELS THAT
ARE BEING USED BY OTHER PROGRAMS
AS WE COLLECT A LOT OF DATA ON
OUR CLIENTELE.
AND WE HAVE A TEAM OF
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS WHO WHO ARE
ANALYZING THAT DATA SO.
WELL THAT WHILE THE PROGRAM
MIGHT LOOK AT SAN BERNADINO AS A
WHOLE WERE ABLE TO DRILL DOWN BY
PROBABLY BY ZIP CODE TO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT COME AND KNOW THAT.
THIS GROUP OF WOMEN HERE.
IN THIS AREA ARE MORE RURAL THAN
THE GROUP OF WOMEN OVER HERE IN
A MORE URBAN ZIP CODE SO WE DO
DEFINITELY ARE COLLECTING DATA
AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO DRILL
DOWN AND LOOK AT OUR DATA.
AND LOOK AT WHO'S BEING SERVED
AND THEIR OUTCOMES BENCHMARKS.
AND THEN LOOK AT THE THE BEST --
MODELS BEING USED IN THOSE
PARTICULAR -- ENVIRONMENTS WITH
THE DEBT IS BEING COLLECTED SO
SO WE WILL BE COLLECTING DATA
FROM THE TWO MODELS THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY USING SO WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT THE OUTCOMES FROM
THAT DATA AND THEN IN ADDITION.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT WHAT OTHER
PROGRAMS ARE BEING FUNDED IN
THOSE COUNTIES NOT BY US BUT BY
DSS OUR FIRST FIVE WHAT WHERE
ARE OTHER SERVICES BEING OFFERED
IN TRYING TO FIND AT THE GAPS IN
SERVICES WHERE ARE.
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY PERHAPS
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS GAP BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT THERE OR MAYBE
THERE'S FIRST FIVE IS DOING A
REALLY GREAT JOB WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT PARTICULAR MODEL THEY'RE
USING.
THERE IS A NEED FOR A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF PROGRAM AND SO WE MIGHT
THINK WOW WELL THERE'S THE GAP
THAT WE NEED TO FILL IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY.
WERE ABLE TO LOOK AT OUR DATA
AND THEN WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEING OFFERED BY OTHER
PROGRAMS.
SO THAT WE GET A CUMULATIVE LOOK
AT WHAT'S THERE.
GOING BACK TO DATA -- DO WE HAVE
THE DATA ABOUT.
THAT SHOWS HOW MANY.
MOTHERS HOW MANY FAMILIES ARE
BEING SERVED IN EACH OF THE
COUNTIES.
YES WE DO COULD YOU PROVIDE THAT
TO US YES AND IF IF ANY OF THE
TRIBES ARE BEING -- SERVICE
COULD YOU PUT BE SPECIFIC IF
THEY'RE THERE ARE SPECIFIC
TRIBES ARE BEING SERVED
ABSOLUTELY.
EARLIER YOU SAID THAT YOU WOULD
BRING BACK THE NEW MODEL FOR
APPROVAL.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT PLEASE SO
WE HAVE WE HAVE AN APPROVAL
PROCESS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THROUGH OUR CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH AND THROUGH OUR
OUR NCH DIRECTORS AS A
COLLECTIVE.
THAT THE MODELS THAT WE'RE
SELECTING ARE ARE SOMETHING THAT
THAT ARE GOING TO MEET THE NEEDS
AND SO WE WE JUST.
WE DON'T MAKE IT IN A VACUUM WE
HAVE WE'VE GOT INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT
A HAVE AN APPROVAL QUOTE UNQUOTE
APPROVAL PROCESS WERE GETTING
INPUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SELECTING THE BEST THE BEST
MODEL.
INPUT FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS
CORRECT AND THEN ALL.
STAKEHOLDERS MEANING ARE AND
STAGE DIRECTORS AND OTHER CBO IS
ON THE GROUND THAT WOULD HAVE
INTEL ON THE POPULATION.
I THINK THAT THE THE BIGGEST
CONCERN.
THE WE'VE HEARD FROM ADVOCATES
HAS TO DO WITH HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO TAKE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND I THINK GOING BACK TO THE
COMMENTS THE STAFF COMMENTS.
ON PAGE.
TWENTY ABOUT WHETHER THESE
ACTIVITIES COULD OVERLAP.
EACH OTHER IN YEAR.
ONE AND I THINK YOU SAID THAT
THEY COULD.
WELL WE'RE WORKLOAD THE WORKLOAD
OVERLAPS BUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
DOES NOT SO IN THE FIRST YEAR
DEFINITELY WE WILL HAVE MORE
MONEY OUT TO OUR EXISTING --
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE THAT'S
SIMPLE TO GET MORE.
GET AGREEMENTS AMENDED AND GET
MONEY OUT THE DOOR.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US LONGER TO
LOOK AT WHERE THE GAPS ARE.
AND ANALYZE WHAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO THEN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HOW TO CHOOSE.
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS.
AND MOVE THAT MONEY OUT.
SO THAT'S THE IT IT CERTAINLY
THE WORK WILL BE HAPPENING IN
YEAR ONE BUT WE WON'T GET TO THE
END AND BE READY TO IMPLEMENT IN
YOUR ONE SO WHAT IN YEAR ONE IT
IT'S EXPANSION OF EXISTING SITES.
SO PROVIDING MORE MONEY TO THOSE
COUNTIES WHICH ARE ALREADY
GIVING MONEY.
TO EXACTLY SO THAT THEY CAN
EXPAND THEIR CASELOAD WITHIN.
THEIR AREA OF REACH.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT FOR SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY I DON'T LIKE
THAT IDEA.
BUT I UNDERSTAND.
AND OF MY COLLEAGUE IS NOT FROM
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BUT WE WE
CLAIM HER BECAUSE SHE HAS SHE
HAS TAUGHT IN OUR COUNTY THAT'S
RIGHT.
REMEMBER THAT CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S RIGHT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MS ROOM.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA STAY RIGHT HERE ALL
RIGHT TO THE NEXT ISSUE NUMBER
SIX BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
EXPANSION.
OTHER CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT DECLINES IN ITS
OVERALL INFANT MORTALITY RATE
AND ITS CURRENT AND IS CURRENTLY
RANKED THIRD IN THE NATION WITH
THE LOWEST INFANT MORTALITY RATE.
THE RATE OF MORTALITY AMONG
BLACK INFANTS DYING BEFORE THEIR
FIRST BIRTHDAY CONTINUES TO BE
MORE THAN TWO TIMES HIGHER.
THAN WHITE INFANTS KALIFORNIA
ALSO RANKS FIRST IN THE NATION
WITH THE LOWEST MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE GET AFRICAN
AMERICAN MOTHERS ARE NEARLY FOUR
TIMES AS LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES THAN
WHITE MOTHERS.
YEAH IMPROVEMENTS IN CLOSING THE
GAP BETWEENBLACK WHITE INFANT
AND MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES
HAVE BEEN MADE IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE SO
ALL FAMILIES REGARDLESS OF RACE
REALIZE THEIR DREAMS.
CD PH REQUESTS FOR POSITIONS AND
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUNDS.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN STATE
OPERATIONS AND SEVEN MILLION AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE IN STATE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO EXPAND
OUR B. I. H. PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
PLAQUE MATERNAL AND INFANT
HEALTH.
CITY PH REQUEST FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF OUR
CURRENT AT THE I. H. MODEL.
INCLUDING ADDING STRATEGIES TO
INCREASE PARTICIPANT RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION DATA COLLECTION
EXPANSION OVER B. H. SITES AS
WELL AS MODEL REFINEMENT.
IN YEAR ONE WE WILL FINALIZE OUR
EVALUATION OF R. B. I. H.
PROGRAM WE WILL INVEST IN THE
EXPANSION AND RETENTION OF
PARTICIPANTS AT CURRENT THE I.
H. SITES.
WE WILL EXPAND THE CURRENT B. I.
H. DATABASE AND SET PERFORMANCE
MEASURES.
AND DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
DISPARITIES AWARENESS PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN.
IN YOUR TO WE WILL CONDUCT A
MODEL A. B. I. H. MODEL REVISION
BASED ON OUR EVALUATION RESULTS
WE WILL PROVIDE TA TO IS
EXISTING B. I. H. SITES AND
RELEASE AN RFA. TO ALLOW
EXPANSION OF B. I. H. TWO NEW
TARGETED VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ARE EXCUSE ME COMMUNITIES.
WE WERE IN YOUR THREE WILL WILL
COLLECT AND ANALYZE DATA
PERFORMANCE MEASURES HOMEOWNER
MODEL FIDELITY AND MONITOR THE
PROGRESS OF OUR PROGRAM.
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE EFFORTS
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THE TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND BLACK WOMEN THAT
DELIVER IN CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR
HAVE AN EQUAL CHANCE OF HAVING A
HEALTHY BABY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
WELL I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS
ANOTHER.
VERY GOOD INVESTMENT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S -- ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNOR AND I THANK HIM FOR
THAT [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
LET'S BRING IT TO THE TO THE
PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE TO APPLY THE
GOVERNOR FOR THIS INVESTMENT WE
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT ONE
THING THAT I'VE HEARD FROM MY
MEMBERS WHO ARE THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS IS THAT THE
BACK INTO HEALTH PROGRAM AS IT
STANDS TODAY IS VERY.
PRESCRIPTIVE AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY IN ALL JURISDICTIONS
IT'S NOT WORKING AND GIVING US
THAT THE EVIDENCE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IN ADDRESSING%
AFRICAN AMERICAN MATERNAL AND
INFANT MORTALITY -- I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THE IMPLEMENTED AT A
DIFFERENT STRATEGY -- THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY IN LINE WITH THE
BACK INTO HEALTH PROGRAM BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING REALLY
FAST TURNAROUND IN THEIR DATA
AND SEEING -- ALLOW YOU TO READ
OF THE DISPARITIES BEING
ADDRESSED AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AS THE BACK INTO
HEALTH PROGRAM HAS THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AND DEDICATED TO IT TO REALLY
OPEN THE CONVERSATION AROUND
WHAT INTERVENTIONS COULD WORK
ALLOWING US AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO TEST DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MODELS.
BASED ON THE POPULATIONS THAT WE
SERVE AND THE TYPES OF
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE AND
REALLY TRYING TO SEE IF THAT WE
CAN BUILD SOMETHING THAT IS
EVIDENCE BASE THAT COULD APPLY.
AND IT MAY NOT BE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IN CALIFORNIA
BUT WE DO NEED THAT FLEXIBILITY
BECAUSE WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY CONSIDERING THE
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN AND
MATERNAL MATURE MORTALITY AND
BLACK AND THEN A WEEK TO APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE MARCH OF DIMES
OUT LIKE THAT COMMA COMMENTS OR
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
PART PART OF ME -- MARCH OF
DIMES AND AS DENNIS SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I WANTED -- TO WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT -- WE
FIND THAT THIS RECALLS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND WILL
TRULY -- IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
WOMEN AND AND CHILDREN ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
I APPRECIATED THE COMMENT ABOUT
THE FLEXIBILITY IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
CONSIDERED.
SO WE HAVE AS YOU MAY KNOW WITH
YOU ALL -- THE GOVERNOR GAVE US
MONEY LAST YEAR FOR SOMETHING
CALLED THE PERINATAL EQUITY
INITIATIVES THAT WE RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP AUGMENT OUR
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM.
WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE THAT
TOXIC STRESS IS A IS A KEY
COMPONENT OF POOR BIRTH OUTCOMES
AMONG SAYS POPULATION WE KNOW
THAT ARE BLACK AND THAT HEALTH
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED.
TO ADDRESS THIS TOXIC STRESS
THAT THESE BLACK WOMEN ARE
EXPERIENCING.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ARE THAT
OUR OUR EVALUATION DATA IS
ANALYZED TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAS WORKED AND WHAT HASN'T
AND TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW IT
HAS IMPACTED THIS TOXIC STRESS
THAT IS OCCURRING.
SO WE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL
BE MODEL REFINEMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE NECESSARY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE DATA IS TELL US TELLING US.
IN ORDER TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ON HOW TO READJUST THE
MODEL GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THE WOMEN THAT WE INTEND TO
SERVE.
WE KNOW THAT THE PERINATAL
EQUITY INITIATIVE HAS
INTERVENTIONS THAT WILL AUGMENT
THE CORD BE AYE EACH PROGRAM WE
SEE IT AS A WRAP AROUND. TWO RBI
H. PROGRAM AND WE ARE WORKING
CURRENTLY WITH COUNTIES WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN IN PERSON
MEETING TOMORROW TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT M. INTERVENTIONS ARE REALLY
GOING TO HELP SUPPORT AND
AUGMENT.
THE THE SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED AT THE COUNTIES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE WOMEN THAT
ARE THAT ARE BEING SERVED.
THANK YOU SO CONSISTENCY AND
SOME FLEXIBILITY YEAH.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M HAPPY SANTA KERR IN THE NEW
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY.
AND I'M AND I'M SICK OF A
INCIDENT OCCURRED DOCTOR FOR THE
CIRCLE OF CARE QUALITY.
SO THE BRACES ST OVERVIEW OF OUR
ESTIMATE AS REQUESTED.
SO THE CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY SERVICE MANY ROLES FOR
CD PH ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
ROLES IS OUR LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WHERE WE
OVERSEE AND THE REGULATE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND FACILITIES.
IN THIRTY DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FACILITY TYPES WE ALSO OVERSEE
THE CERTIFICATION OF NURSE
ASSISTANTS HOME HEALTH AIDS HE
MEANT ON DIALYSIS TECHNICIANS
AND LICENSING OF NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATORS.
OTHER ROLES THAT WE SERVE OUR
ALL SU THE PROGRAM FOR HEALTH
CARE SATIATED INFECTIONS -- SO
ARE H. I. A PROGRAM WHICH SERVES
MORE OF IT PREVENTION AND
SURVEILLANCE ROLE -- TO PROTECT --
HOSPITAL ACQUIRED INFECTIONS IF
YOU WELL.
SO FOR FUNDING SOURCES WE HAVE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES SOME OF THEM ARE
OBVIOUSLY ARE FUND THIRTY NINETY
EIGHT WHICH IS OUR PENALTY FIND
WE HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
GROUNDS WE DO REIMBURSEMENTS
ASSOCIATE WITH AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES -- AND SOME
GENERAL FUND. FOR THIS CURRENT
YEAR AS AN OVERVIEW WE THE
BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATED. TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION TO CD PH N. WE ARE
ASKING FOR ADVICE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY AT TUNER NINETY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF TEN POINT TWO
MILLION OR THREE POINT 6% -- FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SEATS YOU
SEE EIGHT C. Q. ESTIMATES
EXPENDITURES WILL TOTAL THREE
HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF
THIRTY POINT THREE MILLION.
OR TEN POINT 8% COMPRISE
COMPARED TO THE TO THE TO
EIGHTEEN BUDGET BACK.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE UNDERGOING -- IF
YOU CHANGES -- SO I STARTED HERE
IN DECEMBER AND BUT LONG BEFORE
I CAME HERE WE WERE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY MAKE THE OUR
SURVEYOR AND VACANCY RATE --
DROP DOWN TO FOUR POINT 2% AND
ALSO OUR SEATS HE Q. WIDE --
VACANCY RATE IS NOW DOWN 26% --
RIGHT NOW WE'RE UNDERGOING -- AS
SEVERE OR WHAT I WOULD SAY --
RETHINKING OF HOW WE DO OUR WORK --
WE HAVE CURRENTLY ALREADY
CURRENT STATE -- PROCESS MAPPED
ALL OF OUR LIFE CYCLE PROCESSES
FOR EVERY TOUCH POINT THAT WE
THAT WE INTERSECT WITH OUR
FACILITIES AND PROVIDERS.
AND WE ALSO DID A FUTURE STATE --
LEAN SIX SIGMA -- PROCESSING MAP
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH MORE
STREAMLINED WAYS SO THAT WE CAN
BE MORE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE --
WE ALSO NOW ARE.
GOING TO BE RESTRUCTURING SOME
OF OUR DISTRICT OFFICE
FACILITIES -- HOW WE DO OUR WORK
AND REALIGNING IT WITH
HEADQUARTERS AND -- THE WHOLE
MAIN PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO START
TO ONCE WE HAVE THIS NEW
PROCESSES TO THEN AND FUSE IT
WITH TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S THE THEN WERE ABLE TO USE --
MODERNIZED WAYS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE SERVING IN OUR FACILITIES
CURRENTLY WE OVERSEE OVER TEN
THOUSAND FACILITIES THROUGH
MAINLY MANUAL PROCESSES AND
PAPER OR ELECTRONIC MANUAL
PROCESSES RATHER THAN AUTOMATED
PROCESSES THAT'S GOING TO BE OUR
HUGE GOAL OVER THE NEXT. ONE TO
TWO YEARS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SENATE PADDOCK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICE
WOULD JUST NOTICE SORT OF ECHO
WHAT -- IS STARTING HER SAID IS
THAT IT'S AT THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY ISRAEL HAS
REALLY BEEN GOING UNDER GOING AT
A TRANSITION AND HOW IT DOES.
ITS WORK I MEAN IT REALLY CAME
UNDER FIRE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
FOR SOME SOME PROBLEMS IN THE
QUALITY OF THEIR WORK IN THAT
AND BACKLOGS IN THE TIMELINESS
OF RESPONSES.
AND YOU KNOW OUR OFFICE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR PROGRESS WE
EXPECT AT SOME POINT TO THE
STAFFING LEVELS THE FEES -- THE
BACKLOGS -- YOU KNOW THE
APPROACHES THE A. T.
IMPLEMENTATION ALL OF THESE
THINGS WILL START TO STABILIZE
AT SOME POINT IN A A YOU KNOW
IT'S AT THAT POINT THAT WILL
REALLY EXPECT TO START SEEING.
THE RESULTS FROM FROM ALL OF
THOSE EFFORTS.
WE CAN YOU [inaudible]
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
NO DIFFERENT FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
THE PUMP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BARBER
GLAZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE FEE
INCREASE PROPOSED IN THIS YEAR'S
STATE BUDGET.
AND LET LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE THAT ILLUSTRATES WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RATE OF
INCREASE SINCE THIS IS THE SIXTH
YEAR IN A ROW WHERE WE'VE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE ABOUT. 20%.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN A TWO
HUNDRED BED HOSPITAL PAID A
LICENSING FEE OF ABOUT FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT SAME HOSPITAL IS GOING TO
PAY A FEE OF ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
YEAR THIS IS A TWO HUNDRED BED
HOSPITAL IF THAT HOSPITAL IS
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THEY WILL PAY IT WILL PAY A FEE
OF ONE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO WE'VE SEEN A STEADY INCREASE
HAPPENING OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS WE DO WONDER WHEN IS THIS
GOING TO LEVEL OUT.
THE WORK THE DEPARTMENT DOES IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE'RE NOT
QUESTIONING THAT AT ALL BUT
WE'RE NOT SEEN A CORRESPONDING
TIMELINESS IN RESULTS SO I I'M
JUST HERE TODAY TO APPLE OUR
CONCERNS WITH THESE BEING
CREASES.
THEY DO ADD TO THE OVERALL COST
OF HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SIGNED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HOPE
FACILITIES AS REPRESENTS OVER
NINE HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FOUR HUNDRED INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED MICHAEL
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
I WE TO HAVE SEEN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASES IN OUR LICENSING FEES
SINCE -- TWENTY FOURTEEN WELL
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE NEW
LEADERSHIP AT THE DEPARTMENT I'M
VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE PROJECTS
AND THINGS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS UNDERSTAND THEM THE
IMPLICATIONS OF OF THE FEE
INCREASES AND HOW THEY CAN HAVE
AN IMPACT ON REVENUE FOR
FACILITIES -- FOR US ARE -- FEES
WERE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER BED BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
A FOR AN LA COUNTY FACILITY
WHAT'S PROPOSED STARTING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
WILL BE A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
BED.
SO THAT'S OVER 3100% INCREASE IN
OF A LICENSING FEE PER BED FOR
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITY SO
IT DOES HAVE AN IMPACT.
AGAIN WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED A
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD BUT WE
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE NO AND CAN KEEP A
HANDLE ON IMPROVEMENTS AND WHERE
OUR LICENSING FEES ARE ACTUALLY
BEING USED FOR SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO COMMENT THAT I'M
SHOCKED THAT THE THE INCREASES
AND YOU KNOW WITH THE HEALTHCARE
COST GOING UP THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
GOING TO BE PASSED DOWN TO THE
CONSUMER WHICH A LOT OF TIMES
IT'S ALSO ARE MEDICAL PROGRAMS
AND YOU KNOW UNTIL THE FEES FOR
HEALTH CARE.
GOING UP AND HOW DO WE BALANCE
THAT IT'S A RHETORICAL QUESTION.
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION.
MR ALMOST CIRCULAR CHAIR ON THE
SAME NOTE I KNOW THAT -- INLAND
EMPIRE ARE ARIANS AMBER DO YOU
KNOW.
WE HAVE A LARGE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY -- IN OUR AREA SO IT'S
A VERY -- INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BALANCE THAT OUT
AS FAR AS THE HEALTH CARE IN THE
COSTS THAT CONTINUE TO THE ONE
THAT.
SEES THE THE THE BRUNT OF THOSE
INCREASES THAT ARE THERE.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THERE'D BE
SOME MORE -- DIALOGUE OR SOME
MORE DISCUSSION ON THAT DATA
BEING DRIVEN -- I KNOW WE HAD
ANOTHER PRESENTATION AND ANOTHER
COMMITTEE.
SOMEWHERE THAT TALKED ABOUT
DIFFERENT RATES IN DIFFERENT
STUDIES SOME BASED ON THE
POPULATION THAT SERVING IN THOSE
AREAS -- LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
SOME MORE THAT DIALOGUE AS FAR
AS HOW WE'RE COMING UP WITH THE
THE INCREASES IN THESE COSTS AND
MAYBE EVEN SOME.
SOME DATA FROM HISTORICAL AS FAR
AS WHERE WE WERE AT TO WHERE WE
ARE NOW.
AND DO WE SEE WERE HAD IT BEEN
AND SOME OF THESE COSTS ARE
MOVING FORWARD SO IT REMAINS A
AN AREA THAT I'D BE INTERESTED
IN LOOKING AT A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER.
THANK YOU STROKES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YES.
I ECHO OTHER A LOT OF THE SAME
CONCERNS IT'S NO EVERY YEAR I
GET ANOTHER CLINIC OR ANOTHER
HOSPITAL OR SOMETHING GOING ON
WHERE.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN
[inaudible]
AND AT I HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
WITH THIS LOOKING AT TO INCREASE
FEES ON THEM -- ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
BECAUSE MY TURN AROUND A THAT IS
YOU KNOW WE AND ACCESS FOR ALL
AND WE NEED.
MORE HOSPITALS AND MORE CLINICS.
AND ALL OF THESE THINGS BUT THEN
YOU GET INTO THE WEEDS ON A AND
YOU KNOW YOU FIND OUT A LOT OF
OUR CLINICS OR OR WAITING FOR
REIMBURSEMENTS AND IT TAKES A
YEAR [inaudible]
OR LONGER. TO GET THE FUNDING
BACK SO THEY HAVE THE FRONT FOR
AN ENTIRE YEAR [inaudible]
AND EIGHT NOW YOU GUYS ARE
ASKING FOR MORE FROM ALL.
AND AND THAT MORE OR IS IT JUST
GONNA COME FROM THEM BUT IT'S
ALSO GOING TO COME FROM.
YOU KNOW OUR FAMILIES.
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD
CALIFORNIA?
YOU KNOW YOU GET 24% OF OUR
PEOPLE AND POVERTY.
AND IT TAKES FROM THREE TO FOUR
WEEKS TO GET IN TO SEE A PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA AS MAKE IT
HARDER TO KEEP THOSE FACILITIES
OPEN IT JUST REALLY.
MAKES ME QUESTION WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AT BECAUSE A A
WHAT WAS SAID BY THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WERE NOT SEEN A GOOD
ARE A WHY.
WITH WHAT YOU ALL OF BEEN
GETTING.
IS EVERY YEAR THERE'S MORE AND
MORE FUNDING GOING TO YOUR
AGENCY [inaudible]
BUT YET.
WHAT WE'RE GETTING BACK?
IS THE SAME HEADACHE WE'VE BEEN
GETTING BACK AND IN ITS THINGS
ARE SLOW TO COME BACK.
IN IN YOU GUYS ARE GREAT WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE I KNOW THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WE HAVE AN
ENTIRE SAY WE'VE GOT TO TAKE
CARE OF WE HAVE MILLIONS UPON
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES THAT NEED
HELP.
AND WE'VE GOT A SEE BETTER
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
AND AND THAT'S MY BIGGEST.
CONCERN ON ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
IT'S BECAUSE THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WE'RE GETTING ON THE
OTHER END [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
IT'S HURTING.
AND WE'RE NOT GETTING.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT ON THE
SIDE FROM THE STATE AGENCY FROM
YOU FOLKS SO HOW HOW IS THAT
GOING TO BALANCE OUT AND WHY
SHOULD WE GIVE THAT TO YOU.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
PAST HISTORY.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
PART OF THESE FEE INCREASES ARE
TO RIGHT SIZE THE SHIP IN THE
SENSE THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
YEARS WERE.
FEES WERE EITHER DECREASED OR
STABILIZE WHEN THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN GROWING WHICH THEN.
THEREFORE THEN WE'RE TRYING TO
RIGHT SIZE EIGHT YEARS LATER
WHICH CAUSES THESE THESE HUGE
INCREASES.
AND I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS AS WELL AS AS FAR AS IN
THE PAST YOU KNOW.
THIS CHANGE TRANSFORMATION OF A
LARGE DECENTRALISED AGENCY
TROUGHOUT THE STATE IT TAKES
TIME TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
TRANSPORTATION ROUTE
TRANSFORMATION BUT THERE DO YOU
NEED TO BE RESULTS AND
ESPECIALLY THIS NEXT YEAR WE
KNEW DEAN IT NEXT YEAR WHEN I
SHOW UP HERE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE DEFINITE R. O.
I. I KNOW ON THE TABLE THAT
NEEDS TO BE SHOWN THAT IS
WORKERS VERY RELEVANT ON WERE
VERY WELL AWARE OF THOSE
SPECIFIC RESULTS WE'RE LOOKING
AT AS FAR AS COMPLAINT BACKLOGS.
AS FAR AS OUR TIME TO PROCESS
THEIR APPLICATIONS AND AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE THAT OUR SURVEYORS
ARE REACHING EVERY FACILITY --
AND GIVING ADEQUATE EFFICIENT --
HELPFUL INFORMATION BACK TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HIGH QUALITY
AND SAFETY AT ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES THAT'S OUR GOAL HERE
IS THAT WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
COMMON GOALS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF US.
WHETHER BE FAMILY MEMBERS
OURSELVES WE'RE ALL PATIENTS AND
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE IN SAFE HIGH QUALITY
FACILITIES.
WELL WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE
THERE THERE ARE SEVERAL OF US UP
HERE ON THE DíAS THAT HAVE BEEN
SITTING IN THE SEATS FOR YEARS
NOW.
AND WE'VE HEARD THESE THINGS
BEFORE [inaudible]
AND WE DON'T SEE DIFFERENT
RESULTS FROM THE AGENCY
REGARDLESS OF WHO THE NEW
DIRECTORS ARE THE NEW HEADS ARE.
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
IF.
THERE'S A MISTAKE MADE IT ON THE
AGENCIES PART.
THEN ONE OF OUR CLINICS IS GONNA
BE PAYING BACK WITH INTEREST. TO
THE AGENCY FOR THAT MISTAKE
[inaudible]
BY.
IT DOESN'T WORK THE OTHER WAY
AROUND.
SO THEY KEEP PAIN IN PAIN IN
PAIN FOR ANY MISTAKES MADE BY
THE AGENCY WITH INTEREST.
AND ARE WE WE GET THE LIP
SERVICE AND WE APPRECIATE IT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO IT MOVING
FORWARD. TO TO THOSE REAL
CHANGES AND WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THE POLICY SIDE.
BUT SOMETHING'S GOTTA GIVE YEAH
AND AND JUST SAYING NO OKAY WERE
WORKING ON IT THAT THAT'S GREAT.
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT AND
THE I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
DEEP DIVE THAT WE ARE DOING IN
CH ACU HAS NEVER BEEN DONE
BEFORE.
I DON'T KNOW EVEN TOLD BY
PREVIOUS DIRECTORS BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT I KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
QUITE RADICAL AND I'M NOT USING
A CONSULTANT TO COME IN AND THEN
FIX IT FOR US.
I'M USING A GRASSROOTS EFFORT OF
PROCESS CHANGE MANAGEMENT WE ARE
DOING WORK STREAMS PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT HIRING -- DIFFERENT
TYPES OF EXPERTS WITHIN
OURSELVES TO BE ABLE TO RIGHT
SIZE BECAUSE THIS IS SO CRITICAL
AM BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN SUCH A
LONG STANDING ISSUE THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD THE LIP SERVICE FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CANDID COMMENTS BECAUSE WE DO
TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY.
THANK YOU ANY TIME TO STOP BY
THE HAPPY TO THE SCORES THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS I THINK THAT
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY
EIGHT TOWARDS THE STAKEHOLDERS
RESPONSE.
JUST AS WAS NOTED THEY THEY
UNDERSTAND THERE'S GOING TO BE A
FEE INCREASE.
CONCERNS REFLECT THE STEADY
INCREASES OVER THE PAST MANY
YEARS COUPLED WITH ALLEGE THAT
LACK OF PROGRESS ON PROVIDING
MORE TIMELY SERVICE.
AND I I DO HOPE AS MR MATHIS HAS
INDICATED IN MY OTHER COLLEAGUES.
THAT TO AND NEXT YEAR THAT WE
WILL HEAR NO MORE FEE INCREASES.
AND THE BACKLOG HAS BEEN TAKEN
CARE OF AND I THINK THEY WILL
KNOW THAT.
IT WAS DONE TO RIGHT THE SHIP --
BECAUSE THAT BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH
A BACKLOG BEFORE THEY WERE SUCH
A PROBLEM BEFORE.
I THINK THAT THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE MADE.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS?
IT'S OKAY DO YOUR FEE INCREASE
SO LONG AS WE'RE YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF THIS BACKLOG.
BUT DON'T DO THE FEE INCREASE IF
IN THE END WE'RE STILL HAVE TE
BACKLOG AND THE SERVICE IS NOT
BE PROVIDED.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORE COMMON -- MANAGER OR AND TO
ADD ON TO THE DIALOGUE THERE ARE --
SUBSTANTIATE THAT THE RATE
INCREASES THAT ALREADY HAVE BEEN.
INCREASED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I LET'S GO TO ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT OKAY.
SO THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDE
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEARS NINETEEN
TWENTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND FIFTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FROM FUND. THIRTY
NINETY EIGHT FOR ADDITIONAL WHEN
I AM SORRY TO NURSE POSITIONS AT
CAN NINETY THREE SUPPORT AND
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS. TO BE
PHASED IN OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD TO AN ENABLE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO ULTIMATELY ADDRESS
1100% OF THEIR LICENSING
CERTIFICATION.
ACTIVITIES A COMPLAINT OF
WORKLOAD IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
YOU'LL ALSO IMPLEMENT THE PAY
FOR PERFORMANCE CONTRACT MODEL
AND FUNDING 43% ANNUAL
AUGMENTATION TO HE CANNOT. FOR
ANY POTENTIAL INCREASES IN
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT RATES AND
PERSONAL COST.
THANK YOU THE MANY ALSO AS A
COUPLE DIFFERENT QUESTIONS ARE
WITH REGARD TO THIS PROPOSAL --
ONE OF WHICH WAS -- PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT WE ARE --
CONSIDERING AND AS PART OF THE
CONTRACT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO GET APPROVAL -- TO
SUBMIT TO YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT OF AS WELL THE ONLY --
SOME OF THE INFORMATION FROM OUR
CONTRACT THAT WE ARE --
DEVELOPING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE ARE IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
NEGOTIATIONS -- WITH LA COUNTY --
IN TERMS OF GETTING CLOSE TO
HAVING SIGNATURES GOING BACK AND
FORTH AND AND IMPLEMENT THE
PROJECT.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO EXPECT SOME
OF THE DOCUMENTS FROM THE
ATTACHMENTS IN THE CONTACT AND
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND THE L. L. LEO.
THESE WOULD LARGELY BE OF THE
METRICS THAT WE EXPECT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO ME FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS IN TERMS OF THE
WORKLOAD THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE.
MEETING AS THE HIGHER STAFF
TRAINED STAFF CAN WRAP UP TO
ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD.
AS WELL AS QUALITY AND CUSTOMER
SERVICE PERFORMANCE METRICS THAT
WE WILL BE ESTABLISHING AND
MONITOR AND SEE HOW WELL THE
MEETING BOTH THE QUALITY OF THE
OTHER THREE THAT THEY'RE DOING.
BUT ALSO THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
HOW WILL BE RESPONSIVE TO A
GETTING BACK TO PROVIDERS HOW
WILL THE RESPONSE OF TO GETTING
BACK TO COMPLAINTS -- GOOD THANK
YOU.
THE COMMITTEE ALSO ASK -- WHY
THE COST OF THE NURSES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OR MORE THAN THE
STATE BECAUSE IT SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE THE?
EMPLOYEES OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ARE UNDER DIFFERENT CONTRACTING
PARKING UNIT.
THE ERROR OF HAVE A DIFFERENT --
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THE STATE HAS NO AUTHORITY.
TO INTERJECT IN AND THE LOCAL
BARGAINING AGREEMENT FOR
SALARIES AND BENEFITS AT THE AT
THE LOCAL SO IT REALLY IS THE
DRIVING FACTOR FOR Y..
SURVEYORS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ARE PAID MORE THAN SURVEYORS OF
PAID FOR THE SUMMER WORK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
HI SONYA PICK FROM THE LA -- I
WOULD JUST.
SAY THAT WE'RE LOOKING VERY
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT WILL
BE INCLUDED IN THE CONTRACT IT'S
BEEN SORT OF HARD TO ASSESS THE
QUALITY OF THE THE AGREEMENT
WITH LA COUNTY WITHOUT SOME OF
THOSE MORE SPECIFIC DETAILS --
ONE THING THAT'S WORTH NOTING IS
THE LA COUNTY WILL BE TAKING ON
A WORKLOAD THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
DONE BY THE STATE AS THEY TAKE
ON MORE OF THE FACILITIES -- AND
HAVE A CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS -- THIS MEANS
THAT THERE'S A COMMENSURATE
DECREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF STATE
WORKLOAD IN LA COUNTY -- AND WE
WE DID ASK THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
THIS AND THEY SAID THAT THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT CAN BE DONE AT THE STATE
LEVEL WITH THESE POSITIONS THAT
WERE FORMALLY FOCUSED ON LA
COUNTY AND WE WE JUST A THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT WILL JUST CONTINUE.
TO MONITOR IN THE FUTURE -- TO
ENSURE THAT THINGS ARE OPERATING
EFFICIENTLY AND THAT -- THAT
WORKLOAD CAN POTENTIAL -- THOSE
POSITIONS CAM POTENTIALLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RESULTS THAT
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT IN
THE IN THE PREVIOUS -- ISSUE IN
THE AGENDA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HOW MANY FINANCE?
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGELA
BELOW MY DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
LA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
END DOM I'M HERE REALLY -- TO
FIRST THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
INCREASE HIS PROPOSED INCREASE
IN THE FUNDING FOR THE CONTRACT
BETWEEN.
THE STATE DPH AND THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES FOR THIS WORK.
SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL THE
STUDIES AND CRITICISMS THAT WERE
MADE BY THE MEDIA.
OF THIS PROGRAM THE PERFORMANCE
OR LACK OF PERFORMANCE IN
STATEWIDE EFFORTS INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO PERFORM THE
WORK AND PROTECTED THE WERE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS WITHIN
THESE FACILITIES.
ON THE HEELS OF THAT ARE THERE
WERE SEVERAL AUDITS THAT WERE
DONE AND WHAT WE FOUND TO BE AT
THE HEART OF THOSE.
POOR PERFORMANCE -- ISSUES WAS A
CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING OF THE
PROGRAM.
THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES THAT
HEARD THAT YOUR COMMITTEE WAS
ONE OF THEM -- AND MEMBERS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION RESPONDED TO
THAT BY INCREASING THE FUNDS FOR
AT LEAST THE PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE WERE ABOUT TO
ENTER INTO ANOTHER AGREEMENT.
WE'VE BEEN CONTRACTING A WITH
THE STATE FOR A YOU KNOW THE
PAST THIRTY PLUS YEARS.
BUT WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THE
PROGRAM WAS RIGHT SIZE SO THAT
WAS AN AMAZING.
INCREASE IN FUNDING AND IT PUT
US ON THE RIGHT TRAJECTORY.
WE FINISHED OFF THE FOURTH YEAR
OF THAT CONTRACT WHICH WAS
PENNED IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND DAH
WERE IN A COUPLE MONTHS WILL BE
DONE WITH THE FOURTH YEAR IT WAS
A THREE YEAR CONTRACT WITH A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION.
WE MET IN IN MANY CASES EXCEEDED
THE CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
WITHIN THECONTRACT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW AS WE MOVE
OFF OF THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW
IS THAT WE ARE?
DEVELOPING A NEW CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE.
THAT WILL BE A PERFORMANCE BASED
CONTRACT IN IT WILL DEAL WITH
NOT ONLY THE METRICS THAT WERE.
REFERENCED BY THE STATE BUT IT
WILL ALSO DEAL WITH THE BACKLOG
THIS IS BEEN A CONCERN OF PHILLY
COUNTY THE STATE AND THESE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES.
AND THAT A BACKLOG WILL BE THERE
WILL BE NO NEW BACKLOG GENERATED
AND THE EXISTING BACKLOG WILL BE
CUT IN HALF.
DURING THE FIRST THREE YEARS AND
WILL BE DONE SUBSEQUENTLY.
ARE.
ELIMINATED IN NAM STARTING IN
THE PERIOD -- TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WITHOUT ALL LOG.
OF OF CONCLUDE HERE AND NEXT UP
IS SAW A MARKET RUN TO SEE FROM
LA COUNTY ALSO SHE'S OUR CHIEF
OF THE A PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A MARK AROUND
ITS THE THE CHIEF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
HEALTH FACILITIES INSPECTION
DIVISION IN JUNE TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE COUNTY HEALTH FACILITIES
INSPECTION DIVISION WAS PLACED
UNDER MY DIRECTION.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S CURRENT
CONTRACT EXPIRES ON JUNE THIRTY
TWO IN THE NINETEEN AND I'M
PROUD TO SAY THAT THE COUNTY HAS
MET AND IN SOME CASES.
EXCEEDED ITS CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS IN THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF A CONTRACT NOW WE ARE
ON TRACK. TO MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS THROUGH THE END OF A
CONTRACTOR.
UNDER THE NEW CONTRACT OFFENDER
WAS COUNTY WILL GRADUALLY AS IN
FULL RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
WORKLOAD GENERATED BY HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
IN THE COUNTY OVER THE COST OF A
THREE YEAR TERM.
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED
INVEST CURRENT CONTRACT.
THAT WE ACT CAPABLE [inaudible]
SKILLED.
STRATEGIC F. AND ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT PROVIDING THESE VITAL
SERVICES TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN LA COUNTY.
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT AS
HE CONTINUE WITH YOUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS THANK YOU -- GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS TODD YEOMANS
I'M A SENIOR HEALTH FACILITIES
EVALUATOR NURSE WITH THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AND I'M A MEMBER
OF SEIU LOCAL SEVEN TWO ONE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN TWO
AND MEMBERS -- I WAS HIRED AS A
RESULT OF THE LAST CONFERENCE
CENTER THE POSITION THAT -- I'M
SORRY I WAS HERE AS I'M WAS HURT
AS A RESULT OF THE LAST CONTRACT.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OF FUNDED --
SEIU SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET TO FULLY FUND LA
COUNTY IS A LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
I'M THE PREVIOUS FUNDING HELPED
ENABLE US TO EXCEED SOME OF THE
WORK IN OUR THIS CONTRACT AS
STATED BY MS OR A NEW CD -- AND
ALSO GAVE US THE STAFFING AND
RESOURCES TO CATCH UP ON OUR
BACKLOG -- WE HAVE GIVEN OUR
BEST EFFORTS TO PROVE THAT -- WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO WHAT IT
TAKES TO TAKE ON THE REST OF THE
WORK IN LA COUNTY.
SO PLEASE IN TRUST US AND THE LA
COUNTY AND REGISTERED NURSES AND
STAFF.
AT TO SERVE AND PROTECT THE
RESIDENTS OF ELK HUNTING
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANTE VARIOUS
WITH SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
REPRESENTING NINETY SIX THOUSAND
STATE EMPLOYEES INCLUDING THAT
STATE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE THAT
HELP FACILITATOR -- A VALUE
HEALTH FACILITY VALUATION NURSES
THAT WORK FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M JUST TWO QUICK
POINTS I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE SORT OF BRIEF
BUT DISCUSSION ON THE
DISCREPANCY IN THE SALARIES --
MY MEMBERS WORK SIDE BY SIDE BY
THE WITH THE WITH THE S. YEAH
YOU -- SEVEN TWO ONE AND THEY
HAVE THE SAME -- LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STATE
EMPLOYEES AND YOU KNOW WE SORT
OF FIELD PARITY IS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS DO AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT ON AND THE SECOND
POINT IS I HEARD AND I THINK IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN.
A BUDGET ITEM SEVEN BUT THE THE
VACANCY RATE OF MAYBE LOWER AND
I DID I'VE READ THE ANALYSIS AND
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S IT'S GETTING
LOWER.
BUT WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALSO
LOOK AT THE TURNOVER RATE SO
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FROM A
NURSE THAT'S IN I BELIEVE IT'S
IN RIVERSIDE.
THAT -- SHE HAS WORKED THERE FOR
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AND THERE HAVE
BEEN THE TURNOVER FOR THAT WE
CALL THEM HAPPENS TO HELP US
EVALUATE A NURSES -- IS REALLY
HIGH IN THERE IT'S LIKE YEARLY
THAT THERE ARE NEW NURSES COMING
IN SO THERE IS A WAY I THINK --
TO YOU KNOW CAPTURE SOME OF THAT
SAVINGS IF THE IF THE TURNOVER
RATE WASN'T SO HIGH BECAUSE
YOU'RE.
YOU KNOW THESE THESE PEOPLE
COMMEND YOU TRAIN THEM AND IT'S
MONEY AND TIME AND THEN THEY
LEAVE. TO GO TO LA COUNTY OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE QUITE FRANKLY SO
I JUST WANT THANK COMMITTEE AND
HAVE A GOOD THING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
JUST FOLLOW UP ON THAT NOT
COMMON AS FAR AS RETENTION --
RETENTION THE COST OF DOLLARS
I'M COMING IN MAYBE WE COULD SEE
SOME TYPE OF DATA.
ON LOOKING AT HOSE OF DIFFERENT
TURNOVER RATES AND HOW FAR OUT
THE RETENTION GOES TO ENSURE
THAT WERE -- UTILIZING RESOURCES
EFFICIENTLY [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
VERY GOOD -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE CONCLUDES.
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER REMAINING ISSUES.
FROM ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
NINE THROUGH.
TWENTY TWO OR NON DISCUSSION
ITEMS BUT IF THERE'S A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ANY OF THOSE.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NONE I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US FOR SUB --
ONE SUB BUT JUST HAVE ONE
COMMITTEE -- TODAY AND THIS
MEETING STANDS ADJOURNED